you're Regina Hall you can't just you
can't just go out and date the way other
people date too many people are gonna
say oh my god Regina Howe of course I'm
gonna go on that date where do you think
you can meet men today being Regina Hall
where can you meet men and find really
good guys uh well maybe I could where do
you go where do you go to meet guys I go
to a gay bar
[Laughter]
yeah maybe golf golf courses golf
courses you wait a minute no car watches
no what do you in a car wash guys what
they need to have a car so then at least
new you know if they're in a car wash
they have it are gross we do you go to
grocery store yeah grocery stores when I
was single I used to notice there it is
back in the well this is true you'd go
to the grocery store when I lived out
here for the first time and I'd go to
the grocery store I'd see all these
attractive single women that's nothing
to do with me I mean where didn't you
see women and where you saw a lot of men
that's where sure I should be like where
was it uneven uneven yeah like where
were there like more men and like like
two women where did it feel like prison
where will okay when like the Red Sox
when the Red Sox were doing really well
and they were in the game was being
played here in Los Angeles and I would
go to a bar to watch the Red Sox game at
one of those bars where Bostonians go it
was all guys those majority guys yeah
and I'm going to a Red Sox they've got
here know where do they you don't want
to go to you know you don't want to go
to one of those there they all have very
thick Boston accents and it's horrible
okay okay so well then where am i go
this is sure are you asking me introduce
me to someone episodes ago years ago and
nothing Conan nothing well I'm doing the
best I could have a bush no one's gonna
know
[Laughter]
I know but well I you know I I guess
auto parts stores you can't make that
assumption in holding out yes I don't
know okay I'm just you know I've been
married for a million years so I don't
even know where piano anymore yeah well
you're asking the wrong guys yeah I will
do my best to find you a man I will if
and only if you give me an anima Garrity
[Applause]
what are we a deal I just made I know
only if you Jam that hose full of
wheatgrass up my ass how long you can
hold it what's that okay it's a long you
can hold the weak right you know what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna hold it and play
a hop scotch
[Laughter]
you